hi I'm anyway and I'm a mathematics
teacher I know a lot of people out there
are gonna be thinking you know I don't
want to change my practice I'm really
comfortable and confident in the way
that I do things I get great marks from
my students and also this is the only
way that I I was taught and that I'm
uncomfortable with and there are a lot
of ideas out there that can be quite
intimidating to contemplate I think it's
really important to challenge that
assumption about ourselves and to tell
your story that hopefully illustrates
that you know now that I've been doing
videos for six years online I've had
lots of people who've commented and said
hey this is great it's really really
really helpful and it's the life for
getting those comments but I've had
plenty of other comments that have said
actually I I think this is this is a bit
confused so this is unclear or I'd like
to I think it's much better if you say
it this way and it would be you know for
me incredibly short-sighted I think just
to say to the entire world is like no
and my way is clearly the best way how
dare you say that this is a different
way of doing things that that might be
better for me I think it's much more
valuable and powerful for me to remain
open to the fact that yeah I may teach
things one way but maybe there is a
better way to do that a clearer way that
will make sense to more people or even
if it's not a better way just another
way every human being who comes into our
classroom is a unique beautiful
individual and for me that's one of the
things that's most enjoyable about
teaching and that have the same syllabus
every single year but as a high school
teacher I get to interact with a whole
new 120 150 different people I've never
met before and I get to learn what makes
them tick and and and how they have
unique gifts that are going to come into
my mathematics classroom and interact
with them and come out better and richer
and deeper further for the experience
and learning those things learning the
uniqueness of all of those different
kids for me recognizing that and
wrestling with that is just the reality
of you know we don't have we shouldn't
have an industrial model of teaching
where we bring in all of these different
things and treat them all the same way
they're human beings not machines and so
we should treat them like that and be
open ourselves to say maybe there are
new and different ways that are worth
for the sake of the kids
[Music]